and marcus rachel you've been amusing
yourself in lockdown what's the the new
thing you're doing on twitter
yeah well we've listened obviously
during lockdown to a lot of radio
daytime radio
and uh the jeremy vine show became a bit
of a fixture
that we'd listen to it's amazing so
basically if you haven't heard the
the jeremy vine show you'll know from
years ago at radio 2
um the jeremy vine show is a phone-in
show
where jeremy just gets the subject from
the day's news so it doesn't always know
everything about it
but the people ringing in know
absolutely [ __ ] all
right but very opinionated so
jeremy will kick off and the bigger the
subject the better so
loads of people phoning into 88 291 and
jeremy vinegar radio team should
we be putting people in quarantine who
are arriving here we've got a phone call
on line one who we got online one
hello jeremy this is margaret from
cornwall
should we be putting people in
quarantine margaret from colw well
it's a good question generally but let
me first talk to you about electric
won't have it scooters dangerous are
they legal do you need a license for
them
okay well we we do want to stick to the
coving situation if we can
i'll tell you one thing about carving
jeremy there's too many repeats on
television
same film three times this is ed sheeran
so we do that but the lovely thing is
out there jeremy vine retweets them
[Music]
you